popcorn and nachos pretzel nuggets
chicken have you got it I always click
on the tickets that are at the furthest
in the back row way off to the side I
want to be away from people talking and
then maybe after the lights go down I
will find a more a better seat what are
you doing I'm doing I'm doing superhero
stuff dog why not just because they're
sour patch kids
God do that goobers good never not like
the goober myself you know someplace do
a little dangerous thing and go over
quesadillas whose it shouldn't be cooked
in theaters but I still taste them
I still go for it I like to sit 75
percent of the way back like a little
farther back from the middle so I
ordered the smallest thing of popcorn
and I pour out 7080 percent of it into a
trash can and then I would maybe get a
small coke or a water I'm an aisle seat
type of guy always had then reason for
it is because I'm a jumper when you're a
jumper you don't want to you don't want
to jump on people or hit people
somewhere in an aisle you'd be much more
physical so I've always I've always
gravitated towards the aisle seat and
this way I'm not a distraction going
back and forth to the bathroom some
reason my bladder is very very loose
when I go to movies that was weird
Oh sister it's gonna get way weirder
what do I like to eat at the movies
everything I'm definitely someone who
sneaks with candy or and or food and
I've definitely stuffed full
cheeseburgers and full meals into a
movie
[Music]
well I dresses Santa I have a sack full
of burgers if you ever see a Santa Claus
in a movie theater eating the
cheeseburger yes concession compassion
[Music]